[Music]
i just have to say you
you look like you maybe belong in like a
biology book from the 80s
what you look like right now or he's the
slow the spokesperson for don't do drug
ads
no i'm going for the amish look let me
see look at me joe
name one amish person you've ever met
that looks like you
well i got the wrong hat i got the wrong
hat
wrong wardrobe i'm doing that totally
honestly
like i said in the previous video this
is joe except him as he is we all have
no i'm on board i'm just saying she's
totally on board
like if there was like an old vhs of
like an after-school special from like
the 80s that are like
yeah that'll like hey kids i skateboard
but i don't do drugs that's totally what
you look like
right now true right or speaking of kids
kids are now headed back to school
oh cool you know that's not good yes
and if we were all students they were
all going back to our
sophomore year high school oh that's my
favorite how would you guys
deal with the current pandemic i
wouldn't want to go you want to want to
go
no i'd miss checking out the girls
no wait not personally it like with
covid in mind
are you serious because like when i'm a
sophomore i think i thought i was
invincible
so i don't think right any like i think
about
yeah i would want to go to school just
like hang out with people
because i think i discovered [ __ ]
around that time yeah
i think to this generation of high
school is wait
what's sophomore 16 10 15
sophomore kids 16. i was 15. yeah i was
15 15 16.
drugs and yeah drugs waking up at random
strangers houses
yeah that's a sophomore waking up at 2pm
you're not even going to school so you
can't even answer his question
but you have to go to school to make
arrangements you think on weekends maybe
even even during those times i didn't
want to go to school
so yeah i would like i would ditch a lot
yeah yeah
extra reason to your school now but then
now your parents are home and they make
you stay home because
oh crap if your parents are home do you
want to be home no no no no no
take me maybe i would have been loved
and had a great childhood
if corona was around when i was a child
it would have changed my upbringing
maybe true
true all right so uh so la we haven't
had students go back yet well maybe by
the time this video comes out uh
school is in but uh right now georgia
is back in school and here's a little
snapshot
of what georgia schools look like damn
they don't give a [ __ ] they look like i
don't give a [ __ ]
there's like no mask in sight yeah so
how many masks do you see
and then and then how much social
distancing do you see
one zero zero negative insane
people sound like jansport backpacks
right i think they're
they're they're forever gonna be part of
the school like
like scenery yeah i didn't think they
would you would think by now they would
like some other doper companies
yeah or even herschel commercial's too
expensive you don't need to fix what's
not broken you know what i mean
like a jansport backpack is [ __ ] it's
iconic it's like a converse shoe
yeah i remember thinking my aunt she had
a dance floor and she was like my cool
aunt like
like you know she was like the younger
one because i looked up to her a lot
and she always had like doc martin boots
and then she she had her her transport
backpack she was like oh yeah this is
i've had this since high school and it
was like all written up or whatever but
it was like
still in really good condition i
remember thinking like okay
the moment i get a jansport backpacking
i'm in high school like that's it i made
it like
that's my dream she sounds like either
the cheetah print
transport or the checkered jansport kind
of she had a black
black one all black all black with all
of her friends graffiti on
like gel gel pen yeah kind of one of
those girls huh
girls with the cheater print uh
backpacks always uh
was hotter to me for some reason i was
like oh yeah cheetah prince she's hot
yeah you never saw anyone with a cheetah
they usually wear doc martens and
fishnets
or uh i like the one with the with the
suede on the bottom
because are you throwing my [ __ ] on the
ground that's what she has stays
intact man with the brown suede at the
bottom
but like okay so like what are the terms
for returning back to school
uh apparently we're supposed to be
wearing masks
it's like it's it's not a requirement
it's being like
highly encouraged is the word yeah so so
you can't highly encourage things at
kids exactly that doesn't work true
exactly so the person that posted this
photo um she
basically was saying the cdc says one
thing but the school district
is saying another thing like the school
district is saying it's optional to wear
masks
and we're going to go back to school and
we're going to put these kids in the
classrooms because
life needs to go on that's pretty much
the stance that the school district has
taken
is it just one district in georgia or is
it all of georgia
i don't know it's a good question i
don't know either but i did hear that
one of those georgia school district
situations that a lot of the adults that
were participating in meetings to
prepare for kids to go back
there was like a huge number of those
people that got covered because
that was meetings really two put kids
like school board members or something
didn't ben carson just die
from corona carson
who is that wasn't he like a
presidential person
uh at one point at one point yeah i
might have made it up in my brain
because someone might have told me this
rumor in my dream last night
someone told him a rumor in his dream
last night everyone
wrap your hands around that hold on ben
carson or you're checking if they told
you in your wikipedia
the doctor was texting his friend hey
did you tell me this in my dream last
night
yeah he's a conservative uh black
politician doctor he's 68. he's alive oh
he's alive
oh [ __ ] you can't trust your dreams john
my dream told me otherwise
sorry sorry guys oh my god what if it's
a prediction
no no deaths i don't want no maybe
another guy died and then i got it mixed
up
there's probably someone that died
yesterday yeah a black republican though
sure oh
oh i did see that one it wasn't ben
carson but it was a black republican
okay so you're half wrong my brain's
just being racist
oh [ __ ] okay all right but anyway so
uh the girl that posted this photo uh
you know basically captioned let me find
the caption i don't want to just
summarize everything uh oh well she said
it's the first day of school in
paulden county georgia paulding county
is the is where we're at one of those
forgettable counties
yeah and she pointed out which county do
you know in georgia classic
atlanta that's a county nah maybe
well because we have los angeles county
so i'm just guessing atlanta is a county
that's true i don't know anything else
but atlanta and savannah
all right what else do you know that's
it is there any other cities you
reminded me of
there's only two cities in georgia all
right i rest my case
is georgia right above florida yeah okay
thank god all right i know where it's at
otherwise throw everything out the
window we got it all wrong
i just know they got good strip clubs in
atlanta true
so the girl who posted this photo uh
basically
ousted the school for saying hey like
there's no mass going on like no one's
wearing masks
there's no social distancing whatsoever
and the school
retaliated and suspended her for five
days for what tattletaling
or tattletailing yes on what's ground
telling is this public school
this is a public school yeah maybe
because they're minors or something
they're probably telling you're like
oh you can't go find some loophole yeah
or or
you're using your phone during class
hours like class
time it's not but five days for using
your phone
they can't justify that and yeah and
there's a big
backlash on this via twitter and stuff
so that she says the policy that i broke
stated that i used my phone the hallway
without permission
use my phone for social media and
posting pictures of miners without
consent
oh you know that's everywhere everyone
in high school on social media though
they
care like what if she just took a photo
didn't post it they wouldn't even care
they guess well but she used the phone
yeah they're just finding a loop on them
now we got her on three different
terms if she did this and it was
positive like and it made the school
look good
and it's like it went viral she'd be in
the paper you would praise
and then breaking news that just found
out not too long ago thank you jess
i found we found out that she the school
has overturned the decision to suspend
her because of all the backlash
they have to yeah they just look so bad
too much bad publicity
every time an idiot makes a decision for
companies and schools and organizations
they need to bring out that idiot that
made the decision because sometimes you
think it's the whole school
or like you think it's the whole company
but sometimes it's just one
[ __ ] dumb manager and pants them in
public yes that's the best
it's like who's the [ __ ] that made
that that call
and then they're like oh that was
definitely this guy what if it's like a
board member
like board members like a group just
have them all be all stand out
yeah and then in three two one and it's
like an executioner but then they pants
down
students gets to pass them yeah and then
they stand there
and they're just kind of like they don't
know that they're gonna get pants too so
they they can't prepare their underwear
oh that's smart oh so they make it it's
just in case they went commando
like because they could put those
vendors oh i say it's nice
it's like you can't no like they might
have dirty underwear that day really
they're wearing a thong yeah and it's
like guy
yeah that's is that is that a guy
wearing thongs hot
really i'm just going with the flow got
it damn y'all judged me like hella fast
all right and so
uh this girl also won an extra step to
tally up
the amount of people wearing masks to
the number of people that were in
certain classrooms
wow eight people out of 21. now that's
the kind of character
we're wearing masks 9 out of 28 5 out of
30 10 out of 30 four four out of 14 8
out of 23 so
basically you guys are right in a high
school scenario
most people are going to be like [ __ ]
your rules i don't care about nothing
we're invincible even when it's
mandatory people don't do it
oh it's true yeah i'm sure people are
pushing back against that so
this is just developing some a lot of
counties still don't have uh we're not
back at school yet in some counties so
we'll see what that's gonna look like in
the next month or so
and uh i don't know for isaac have you
guys gotten a notice if
he's going back to school or not yes so
they gave us a survey
and they said uh you guys let us know
i i took this as like oh we're just
trying to gauge interest i didn't know
that i was making decisions
oh but apparently i was um so it was
kind of like asking like would you want
your child to be
in online only or in hybrid and so at
the time that i filled out this survey
uh i was like oh well you know isaac's
been
he's been dying to see people and also
he's starting a brand new school so he's
gonna be a new student in the school
and i i had to talk with him like how do
you feel about it like
are you comfortable whatever he was like
oh mom please please can it be hybrid
like i really want to go
into the classroom like i can't learn
right all last semester or like last
year
when he was doing distance learning he
was like it was just so hard like it's
just really hard to focus like i don't
know like i need to be in a classroom
with a teacher
it is it is tough to just learn straight
up yeah i just want
i don't know if i was his age i wouldn't
know what to do
because you have everything you need at
home the internet's better
tv's better shows are better games are
better every you could post mates
whatever
he likes the fact that he gets to sleep
in or like that he wakes up
at like 9 or 10 a.m and then he just
pulls out the chromebook
and is doing his work in the bed he's
like that part is cool but he's like i
know myself mom i really need to go and
like be with the teacher in the
classroom so i ended up opting for the
hybrid
option and now there's so many cute
girls here i've
just got to meet them just yesterday i
think it was or
sometime this week i got an email saying
like okay all schools are
i mean all students are returning back
to school on august 24th
is the first day of school but
absolutely everyone is gonna be online
first so then not until they see it's
appropriate then they're going to move
into the phase of having the hybrid
option
so that's kind of the case with isaac
school isn't it crazy how like
you'll be in l.a and they're like
where's your mask you're not wearing
your mask
and then you go to oc and they're like
why you wearing a mask take it off and
breathe
that's not weird it is funny there's
mask wearing shaming
there is [ __ ] crazy yeah i got mad
shamed when i was at walmart by
magic mountain buying a bicycle i was in
the parking lot and then the employee
was like
breathe the air you could bring in
the fresh air yeah yeah he was pushing
the car
that's not the oc no i know but just
just i was just saying that
i got mashing that's crazy yeah and then
uh um he was putting the cards away and
he was looking at me and he goes
the air is fresh it's a beautiful day
get some air and then he goes
and then he gets grown and he's like all
right and i'll just like i
i don't mind it's just i'm thinking
about other people like
i don't want other people to feel
uncomfortable around me at least that
guy was kind of nice about it he wasn't
like making you feel
bad you know like more negative about it
yeah
that's kind of cool i guess nah that's
so [ __ ] up
hello guys thank you guys so much for
watching all of our videos and i know
it's been a million years in the making
but we finally got
just kidding news merch yep so make sure
you go down to the store below
and you can round around yeah you can
get a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
bye-bye
[Music]
foreign